io sono settimio benedusi faccio il
fotografo mi amo definirmi fascista
fascista con 2 c cioè a me piacciono le
facce mi piace talmente tanto che userei
questo tempo potete illuminarmi
gentilmente che mi piacerebbe farmi una
foto o guardate quante facce siete
bellissimi anche perché da qua non è
facile far rivedere una prima così mi
piacerebbe un po di altre ecco le
braccia in alto ok 123
[Musica]
bellissimi bellissimi allora scusate
aprono mia profilo instagram mentre lo
apro se voi mi date il vostro tag
io vi tardo tutti no tutti un po troppo
propri ma ho conosciuto una ragazza che
capirete dal suo dal suo tag che ha un
bellissimo ironia
si chiama il suo target nana bianca
io nella bianchi tago tango anche ted
verona fine account
tutto pronto verona centro mettiamo
anche sposo condividi
vediamo un po se ci siete
vediamo eccovi qua in diretta bello il
punto di vista di qua no anche dal punto
di vista meravigliosa quindi vedete che
al giorno d'oggi ma già lo sapevate è
facilissimo fare fotografie perché basta
avere questo oggetto che tutti in tasca
voi avete che vi rende tutti i fotografi
qualche maniera perché è sicuramente
linguaggio della contemporaneità
la fotografia e questo a me va bene a me
piace io faccio il fotografo da quando
avevo 12 anni ho cominciato il mio papà
mi ha regalato alla macchina fotografica
ho cominciato subito con la camera
oscura sviluppare e stampare quindi so
magari in maniera un pochino più
complessa rispetto ad esso dove avete
visto è veramente molto semplice
pubblicare le proprie fotografie e
questa è la mia prima fotografia
praticamente lui andrea
ed è esattamente la mia età quindi
quando io ho fatto questa fotografia
ero già fascista vedete in tempi non
sospetti e amavo già le facce
il civ a fotografare le persone perché
fotografare le persone la loro umanità
ho sempre pensato che fosse una cosa
meravigliosa importantissima fantastica
adesso faccio un salto temporale questa
foto l'ho fatta non mi ricordo quando
questa è la riproduzione di una stampa
perché ovviamente io stampa in camera
oscura
però insomma avevo quelle tali quindi 17
18 anni
adesso faccio un salto temporale da
imperia dove sono nato sono andato a
milano ho cominciato a fare il fotografo
professionista e facendo un salto
temporale sono arrivato ad avere la
fortuna di incontrare conoscere
tantissimi personaggi meravigliosi come
ad esempio bebe vio che è veramente una
ragazza fantastica e con lei a fare
diverse copertine tra cui questa qui
quindi so ma ho avuto molto fortunato ho
avuto molto fortuna nella vita e sono
riuscito a concretizzare come oggi ho
sentito da tanti altri ed è sempre
bellissimo concretizzare i miei sogni
però a un certo punto è successo
qualcosa in questa contemporaneità
e successo che sono arrivato arrivati
quei mezzi che peraltro io uso i social
è arrivata la pratica digitale che ha
permesso a tutti di fotografare
per me la fotografia è una cosa
importante è veramente una cosa
importante non semplicemente perché io
faccio il fotografo
la fotografia è importante faccio solo
due esempi perché ha permesso a tutti di
avere il privilegio di avere un racconto
iconografico della nostra faccia prima
dell'invenzione autografi ha solamente
pochissimi l'elite potevano permettersi
di avere in casa un quadro di loro
stessi quelli che poi non permettersi un
pittore da pagare e quindi solamente
principi marchesi papi
io non so quanti di voi qui anno abbiano
a casa un quadro in una bella cornice
dorata del proprio avo di qualche avo di
qualche loro antenato
suppongo che non siano molti però tutti
abbiamo lato grafia dei nostri nonni
abbiamo una stampa a casa in un cassetto
laggiù in fondo del nostro bisnonno del
nostro nonno a seconda dell'età
ed è un privilegio enorme perché questo
fino a pochi anni fa era appannaggio
veramente di pochi e poi un altro
esempio per cui penso che la turchia sia
importante lavora fia ha permesso ci ha
permesso di vedere alcune realtà nella
loro cruda realtà le guerre ad esempio
dei tempi di omero in poi sono sempre
state raccontate come qualcosa di nobile
ed importante di eroico con l'evento
autografi abbiamo visto quale tragedia
sia la guerra quindi la grafia è una
cosa importante ne sono veramente
convinto ha cambiato veramente la
maniera in cui l'umanità guarda
all'altra umanità e guarda la realtà
però è successo quello che è successo
i social e digitali i telefonini e
quindi è successo che tutti usano questa
cosa importantissima per fotografare
cosa tramonti
timi pizze ea me questo mi addolora un
pochino perché quella cosa che è la mia
vita quella con la quale io mi guadagno
da vivere tutto quello che indosso l'ho
comprato facendo il fotografo ha giocato
proprio di professione e allora ho
voluto capire se in questi tempi di
condivisione di socialità di tutti che
fanno foto a tutti a tutto se la
fotografia che è la mia vita potesse
veramente essere qualcosa di veramente
di valore
se veramente la grafia potesse
dimostrare di essere una cosa importante
e allora ho pensato di fare un
esperimento una piccola avventura e cioè
ho deciso di partire da imperia la città
dove io sono nato in liguria e a piedi
fare
276 km verso milano la città dove vivo e
lavoro a piedi non solo uno sportivo non
ho mai fatto corse non ho mai fatto
maratone però volevo rischiare una delle
regole basi della buona fotografia è
prende dei rischi uscire dalla comfort
son per trovare delle risposte magari
dove uno non sa che ci siano e quindi
sono partito a piedi con un piccolo
zaino cappello che ho sempre in testa
serve per tenere al caldo i pensieri li
al fresco e ma qual è la particolarità
non semplicemente andare a piedi da
imperia milano per me già abbastanza
complesso ma volevo farlo con zero soldi
senza spendere neanche una lira ma
contraccambiando la mia sopravvivenza
quella base bere mangiare e dormire con
la mia fotografia che era l'unica
maniera per poter capire se la
fotografia mia ma in generale autografia
si poteva dire
avessi ancora un valore un valore
primario mangiare bere dormire
e sul partito
questa è la legge
il primo albergo questo è il primo
albergo
la prima notte ad alassio poi è solo
dico posso dirlo da ligure voglio dire
cominciare questa cosa proprio in
liguria non è proprio facilissimo la
prossima volta farò verona milano
secondo me potrebbe essere meglio quindi
vedete la faccia del ligure sempre così
ospitale te lo dico da ligure sempre più
digitale io però io andavo lì e non è
che dicessi delle cose particolari
nonché dicessi sono un grande fotografo
fotografato questo quell'altro le
copertine i giornali sono un fotografo
se lei mi dà da bere da mangiare e io le
farò una fotografia e questa era la sua
faccia e fotografia quello che vuole lei
ai suoi cari al suo albergo io sono qua
a disposizione ovviamente non ero in
patagonia nudo quindi non avrei mai
rischiato di essere definire affamato
assetato e senza un giaciglio in cui
dormire
sarebbe stato facile perché il telefono
dire venitemi a prendere però è anche
vero che dal primo secondo
ho messo tutto in diretta sui miei
social quindi qualche maniera insomma no
io li uso ma insomma cerco di farne
anche un uso ponderato diciamo così
quindi insomma mi sono messo in gioco
veramente mi ha dato da dormire questa
gentile signore è il mio il mio cammino
è proseguito qui tra l'altro è stato
bellissimo perché io in questo viaggio
ho scoperto delle cose fantastiche che
vi voglio veramente passare al di là
dell'aspetto fotografico intanto il
fatto di camminare e bellissimo e
meraviglioso perché si vedono io quella
strada lì imperia milano nella mia vita
l'ho fatta a 766 milioni volta
ovviamente in tutte le maniere meno che
a piedi però in questa occasione ho
visto completamente un altro mondo
un'altra realtà per chi vedi dettagli
incontri di persone parli con le persone
e questa è una strada che io manco
sapevo ci fosse lo stato
mana che c'è sopra albenga che li ancora
dai romani
questo è un signore che coltivava fare
che mi ha dato delle fave in cambio
della mia fotografia e questa è una
ragazza che mi ha dato la focaccia e io
gli ho fatto una fotografia
questo sono particolarmente orgoglioso
di questa di questa di questa immagine
perché ero sempre ancora in liguria
nella fattispecie a spotorno e appena
entro spotorno il primo albergo che vedo
erano albergo 4 stelle york e in
continuo a camminare pensando che un
albergo 4 stelle fosse un po troppo per
chiedere questo scambio e poi sono
tornati indietro e domani io faccio lo
sono ci sono un grande fotografo scusate
l'immodestia ma io sono un fotografo
io pretendo un albergo 4 stelle io la
mia fotografia vale e quindi sono
tornato indietro ho rifatto la stessa
ramanzina che faceva tutti lo stesso
racconto anche loro gentilmente mi hanno
concesso di stare di una notte poi non
sono dormito ma anche mangiato
ecco voglio dire subito prima di
dimenticarmi ho sempre bevuto dormito e
mangiato in maniera eccezionale sempre
non ho mai mangiato acqua un panino e
dormito sulla panchina ho sempre dormito
in grandi alberghi mangiato in grandi
ristoranti e ha avuto un'accoglienza
meravigliosa veramente una cosa
fantastica
questa fotografia qui fatta con i
prodotti del loro orto la salvia
rosmarino fave e limoni e sono molto
orgoglioso che sulla pagina facebook di
questo albergo il il la foto profilo
dell'albergo è la mia fotografia e
questo mi rende
[Applauso]
dicevo grandi ristoranti questo è un
grandissimo ristorante che ci a bosco
marengo qua ero già in piemonte aveva
già scollinato dalla tua parte
insomma la cosa importante come vi posso
passare ovviamente proprio presumo
pochissimi di voi ho nessuno faccia il
fotografo però il fatto altri ci hanno
detto oggi no e lo voglio confermare lo
scambio è una cosa molto importante se
io do questo a voi io non ce l'ho più ma
se io do qualcosa che nella mia
competenza
se hai un fotografo un medico un
cantante non so a me rimane e voi ce
l'avete quindi si raddoppia si
moltiplica in qualche maniera quindi
veramente su sembra un po banale sembra
un po una frase di osho però dare è
veramente ricevere questa proprio questa
famiglia questa famiglia eccezionale che
mi ha ospitato in un bed and breakfast
meraviglioso
io ho fatto le foto alle figlie e qui
introduca un argomento molto importante
io a tutti mandavo subito le fotografie
con il club di a e mail con lo
smartphone e chiedevo le persone di
stamparla fotografia perché la croazia
stampata ha un enorme valore
tutti noi abbiamo le ecografie sul
telefonino attenzione rischiamo
rischiate di perderle stampate le
fotografie perché la sprazzi a stampata
è un privilegio enorme anche chi li ha
curato il medico perché ovviamente dopo
pochi giorni ho avuto enormi piaghe alle
piedi ha avuto la ricompensa con una mia
fotografia e poi vediamo un incontro più
bello incontro veramente meraviglioso
che si trascina questo viaggio è
successo qualche anno fa pochi anni fa
però ancora adesso sono in grandi
rapporto con questo signore si chiama
giuliano che ha un bar e un bed and
breakfast
a sassello un paese che fanno gli
amaretti io tuttora ve lo giuro
ogni tanto ricevo a casa uno scatolone
di amaretti da questo signore
questo è la primissima foto che gli ho
fatto non sono arrivato in cambio di un
gelato gli ho fatto lo so grafia poi gli
ho raccontato tutta la rava la fava e
lui ha detto se vuoi rimanere qua a
dormire
rimane qua non dico chi è che posso
fotografare cosa posso fotografare
io ho i miei genitori aveva i suoi
genitori di 90 anni e io non ho
veramente io riguardando ogni volta mi
commuovo perché questi due novantenni
sposi da 61 anni e l'ultima fotografia
che avevano fatta da un professionista e
stampata era quello del matrimonio di 61
anni fa e quindi io l'ho fatta
lo stampata e gliel'ho data e nel bar
gina di sassello c'è questa stampa ma
non solo uno delle delle offese più
grandi che si possono fare a un
fotografo ed è un classico dei classici
tutti noi l'abbiamo detto e anche io
forse qualche volta quando si vede una
bella fotografia diciamo che bella
sembra un quadro no ed è terribile non
sa dire mai
io poi non orgogliosamente posso dire
che c'è un quadro che sembra una
fotografia
perché proprio in questi giorni devo
dire non lo sapevo per fare questa
ricerca per questo talk ho sentito
giuliano e mi ha detto che hanno fatto
un quadro quindi nel bar gila di
sassello non solo c'è la mia fotografia
ma anche un quadro fatto con con il mio
nella mia fotografia
insomma alla fine sono sono arrivato a
milano c'è un detto bellissimo di
hemingway che quando gli chiesero quale
fosse il segreto per fare della buona
letteratura
lui disse ma è molto facile basta
mettersi la manca la macchina a scrivere
e sanguinare e io in qualche maniera
avevo fatto anche quello mi sono messo
la mia
like al collo e o sanguinato e ho capito
che la fotografia ha un grandissimo
valore quindi per favore non usate
l'apertura fare gattini pizze e tramonti
grazie
[Applauso]